donc moi c'est arrivé en 1994 je
travaillais je jouais dans le dîner de
cons
en fait une production de j'espérais et
se dire que gilbert rozon je reconnais
c'est peu ou presque pas à l'époque
qu'on n'avait pas vu mais ce soir là
c'était le soir de la dernière il y
avait une petite fête dans un restaurant
il est venu et sincèrement je n'ai pas
souvenir qui met adressé la parole de la
soirée où kim est portée quelconque
attention c'est j'entends beaucoup
parler de filles qui se sont fait
harceler pendant des mois de cinq mois
j'ai pas dit où le souvenir qui met même
regarder durant cette soirée là et ma
voiture était au garage donc quand je
suis parti il m'a proposé de me
raccompagner parce qu'on habitait dans
le même quartier outremont
à l'époque alors j'ai accepté et on est
parti dans un décapotable 7e préalable
n'y avait rien de déplacé avait rien de
vraiment je me sentais pas du tout en
danger
et puis arrivé chez moi il m'a demandé
de monter dans mon appartement et là je
me suis dit bon ça y avait un problème
et j'ai dit non et coach belge doit
aller promener mon chien et après ça
demain matin je me lève très tôt donc
non alors il m'a dit bachelet promener
son chien avec 1 étoile on part promène
le chien promènent leur chien ça dure
une heure une heure et demie je sais
plus comment m'en débarrasser il va
comprendre il va partir mais finalement
je reviens à la maison et il est encore
là fait que je visite au maire et
gilbert au revoir c'était une belle
soirée merci
il pousse la porte rentrer dans
l'appartement et la première chose que
je me souviens c'est qu'il me plaque au
mur qu'il embrasse qui me l'enlève ma
robe et là je fais ok le jeu sujet pas
comment réagir sincèrement et je me dis
bon ben là soit on s'en va vers une
bagarre soit où je me suis dit qu'est-ce
qui est le plus simple pour moi c'est de
ce double sait faire et donc je me suis
dit ça va durer 10 minutes il va
s'emballer après puis j'en ai
débarrasser et c'est ce qui s'est passé
donc après dix minutes il est parti et
puis et puis ça s'est arrêté là
c'est ça mon histoire mais j'en ai
jamais parlé à personne c'est pour ça
que je suis étonné aujourd'hui que mon
nom sorte parce que j'en ai parlé à
personne parce que dire j'étais en
quelques 100 me dire tu as été
consentant tu l'as fait logique elle
nuance entre être consentante peut en
avoir envie je t'ai coucher avec
quelqu'un pour s'en débarrasser pour moi
c'est pas la définition d' être
consentant jeu après je m'en suis voulu
je me suis dit j'aurais peut-être dû le
repousser mais il faut remettre ça en
contexte j'étais jeune il ya toujours
cette espèce de relation de l'employeur
moi j'étais son employé en quelque part
c'était un homme très puissant donc
capable de moi je commençais ma carrière
là j'étais jeune et capable de barrer
quelqu'un
dans le milieu enfin tout ça m'est passé
par la tête et pour moi c'est sûr que
j'étais pas je m'en voulais je
ressentais en fait la honte que lui
aurait dû ressentir c'est ça qui est
épouvantable c'est que moi je ressentais
la honte et la culpabilité que lui
aurait dû ressentir mais que visiblement
il ne ressentait pas parce que je les
croisais quelques temps après dans un
vernissage est dit tout bonnement excuse
moi j'ai pas eu le temps de te rappeler
il est évident ne sont pas obligés de me
rappeler c'est correct
biya je me suis dit mais c'est
incroyable de lui pense qu on a une
relation consensuelle agréable phone
s'ils pensent que c'est ça avoir une
grosse qu'une femme s'est enfin je sais
pas sur quelle planète vit mais moi
c'est pas du tout ma définition de jeu
dans l'île la relation la qualification
c'est difficile c'est difficile sur le
coup je n'ai pas vécu comme un viol à
proprement parler puisque en quelques
pages avec jamais consenti cet acte-là
mais agression oui certainement il ya eu
un envahissement de mon espace privé il
ya eu une relation que je ne désirais
pas il ya eu il ya eu il n'a pas été
violent mais il ya eu du très nettement
il voulait il voulait arriver à son but
et
il y est arrivé quoi donc certainement
pas une relation moi j'en garde pas un
bon souvenir ça c'est certain
j'étais en 94 34 ans
oui j'étais quand même jamais par les
témoignages des autres
je savais je ne sais pas j'avais entendu
à cette époque là beaucoup de rumeurs et
tout ça après il ya eu l'histoire du
manoir rouville qu'ils sont beaux du
tout surprise qu'il était la croupière
mais en même temps là encore ce qui m'a
surpris c'est que malgré cette
dénonciation il s'en soit sorti avec une
absolution inconditionnelle donc tu te
dis à quoi ça sert de dénoncer est ce
que est ce qu'on a un système de justice
adéquat à ce que parce que finalement ce
n'est pas toujours la victime qui est
finalement placé sur le banc des accusés
dont ça nous incite pas dénoncer ça ne
se décide pas en parler moi je vais
j'avais un sentiment de honte c'est
certain je ne me sentais pas bien avec
ça je n'avais pas envie d'en parler
j'avais pas envie d'en parler et
aujourd'hui je le fais parce que il ya
tout ce moment tome là il ya tous
il ya un vrai western qui est légal et
les allégations d'agression sexuelle un
peu partout donc d'autres femmes le font
et ça ça me donne le courage de faim ce
qui me choque aussi c'est que c'est
difficile d'oublier dans la personne qui
nous a agressés et continuellement dans
les journaux est continuellement encensé
pour ses qualités d'homme d'affaires de
6,2 grand manitou de l'humour etc
et nous on a une autre vision de cette
personne là et on se dit mais quand même
c'est ces débutants quelque part que ces
gens là soient encensé et nous les
victimes ont soit contrainte au silence
par peur des poursuites par peur des
représailles par peur de se faire
traiter de tous les noms par peur de
devoir faire mousser une carrière par
peur de ces deux d'être accusé de toutes
sortes de
c'est toujours dit on a toujours
l'impression que ce sont les victimes
qui sont accusés tu l'as cherché t'avais
pas t'avais qu'à le mettre dehors à
cette faute est acceptée c'est inouï
quand même jamais non je porterai pas
plainte parce que parce que s'il m'avait
réellement violé le mettons 6,6 et un
inconnu me viole dans une ruelle c'est
évident que j'ai porté plainte mais je
sais pas pourquoi
quelque part c'est épouvantable de dire
soit puis de sa relève de la
psychanalyse mais je ressens
probablement le même syndrome que les
gens qui connaissent leur agresseur et
qui veulent pas forcément le dénoncer je
sais pas mais c'est à dire je ne
dénoncerai pas à la police enfin oui
c'est à dire que ce que je voudrais
c'est que ces comportements la arrête
dans notre milieu on est soumis à seurre
de toutes sortes de façons que ce soit
des pressions des réalisateurs pour
qu'on se mettre tout nu à l'écran ou que
ce soit des réflexions un peu déplacé
des espèces de notre métier on est
beaucoup dans la séduction mais parfois
ça dépasse un peu les limites
je sais que tous les milieux je sais
qu'il ya du harcèlement dans tous les
milieux et c'est pour ça qu'il est temps
que les femmes se réveillent et disent
ça suffit ça suffit on veut plus de ça
on veut plus de ce qu'on veut des
relations égalitaires où on veut
travailler en le plaisir on veut que ce
soit agréable on ne pas se sentir
harceler on peut se sentir sous pression
veut pas être obligé de faire des choses
par peur ou pas c'est afin de travailler
dans ce contexte l'heure il faut que ça
change c'est pour ça que j'en parle
aujourd'hui parce que hommes comme
femmes on doit tous se réveiller et dire
ça suffit ou on n'est plus dans les
années
c'est ce qu'ils aient une biographie
demain est le nom qui peut que j'ai
couché tous les producteurs au début de
sa carrière je n'ai plus on en n'est
plus l'heure ça suffit ça suffit le
droit de cuissage se suffit les hommes
préhistoriques ça suffit